je tenais à écrire ces quelques mots
pour exprimer ce sentiment d'amour qui
me vient en me refusant le fil de cette
semaine qui a été intense profonde pour
moi et j'en avais vraiment besoin le
silence que que j'ai vu à travers toi
Jean-Marc a été transcendant tu m'as
transcendé vraiment oh
ici en fait il y avait tellement
de bienveillance j'étais j'ai été appelé
ici et vraiment c'est c'était très
important pour moi vous savez pas à quel
point
je remercie vraiment le ciel de m'avoir
répondu à mon appel parce qu'il y a
quelqu moi j'ai j'ai demandé
donade ça va aller ça va
aller je vais finir ça vas-y on est là
il reste tris l c'est
bon et ici j'ai rencontré